what would you call a company if it had
five CEOs in two weeks like imagine if
they said Apple has gone through five
CEOs in 12 days you would say that
places and shambles right what if I told
you a country that just a hundred years
ago was a top 10 GDP country in the
world goes through five presidents in a
span of 12 Days in 2001 and that's
Argentina let me tell you about these
five presidents so it started off with
Fernando de la Rua who was the president
and he served for two years then comes
Ramon Puerta he lasts two days you ever
had a job for more than two days maybe
you last had a job for a week or a month
you felt bad about it don't worry this
guy was a president at Argentina just
for two days then you have Adolfo
Rodriguez cell who lasted eight days and
then you have Eduardo Camano who lasted
three days and last but not least 10
comes Eduardo dualde who ends up serving
for one year but these guys had five
presidents in a span of 12 days it's a
mess of a country when it comes out to
economy they got a new guy running for
office his name is Javier Miele who
looks like the Archie Argentinian Elvis
Presley check out the sky sideburns by
the way absolutely impressive what this
guy's got going on good looking guy
libertarian lawmakers got a lot of crazy
policies some love him because they're
sick of it some are worried about him
calling them a radical but regardless of
what's going on the reason why it's
important for us to study Argentina is
because Argentina out of all the money
they make their Federal expenditure they
spend 62 percent of it around 62 percent
on welfare and America's on track for
this if we don't learn from countries
like Argentina having said that let's
see what's going on with Argentina
foreign
give it a thumbs up and subscribe to the
channel let's get right into it before I
get into the history of what's going on
and what some of the solutions are and
how high their inflation hit and what
their budget looks like in the history
of what they're trying to do to go to
dollarization with this new candidate I
want to first read you three quotes from
people on what they said with welfare
state and what it leads to the first one
is from a president Ronald Reagan he
said welfare's purpose should be to
eliminate as far as possible the need
for its own existence meaning here's
welfare so we can get rid of people
needing welfare here's what Von Misa
said about welfare the welfare state is
merely a method for transforming the
market economy step by step into
socialism which means countries that are
coming up with welfare they eventually
want to turn this country into
socialistic society and last but not
least Ein Rand said the difference
between a welfare state and a
totalitarian state is a matter of time
meaning eventually it's going to be a
totalitarian state again you may be
watching the same pad I don't live in
Argentina why should I care about Argent
because the edge that you have the
biggest Advantage you have is to study
case studies they're smart and then
there's whys we can be smart and have to
go through the problem ourselves and fix
it that's what smart people do but
wisdom is to study other people's
mistakes like Argentina so it doesn't
happen in your country especially if you
live in America so let's take a look at
Argentina 100 years ago Argentina was
one of the world's most prosperous
Nations a military coup in 1930s
suspended the 1853 Constitution modeled
after the U.S Constitution this created
a fascist environment that was hostile
towards businesses General Juan Perron
which by the way you're going to hear
that name all the time and the last I
think 20 presidents they've had 16 of
them have been peronis is what they'll
call it that guy's a piranhas meaning
he's part of the lineage and thinking of
Peron this guy who ruled from 1946
through 1955 and again briefly in 7374
he modeled his ideology after Benito
Mussolini from Italy who was a fascist
prior to 1930 Argentina was amongst top
10 richest Nations per capita today more
than 4 in 10 argentinians live in
poverty so let me tell you why this is a
problem if you look at this chart here
on what's going on with Argentina in
regards to their inflation look what it
was like in January of 2018 which was at
roughly 25 30 percent today it's at a
hundred percent folks in Argentina if
you're in America right now saying oh my
God inflation is so much imagine if
Argentina was at 100 and by the way this
is not the worst Argentina went through
if you look at Argentina since the 70s
look how high they hit at one point
their inflation was three thousand
percent of inflation is where they hit
and by the way this wasn't too long ago
this was in the late 80s 1989 when they
hit 3 000. so you may say well how does
this happen how do you get to a places
like this well let me give you their
2023 proposed budget and see where
they're spending most of their money
this is Argentina government's budget
breakdown for 2023. look at the amount
of money that they're spending towards
just social welfare then economic
Services then they're paying off their
debt then you have government
Administration defense and security and
what's crazy is it it's as if they
haven't learned their lessons Argentina
has defaulted nine times in their
history and then going back to doing it
again they apparently want to default
one more time as if they have not
learned from their own previous mistakes
following this peronis philosophies of
Mussolini fascist way of running a
country so let's go all the way back to
1800s with Argentina after declaring
independence from Spain in 1816
Argentina's economy opened itself to
foreign trade Argentina sold bonds to
help Finance itself the debt came under
pressure when Bank of England raised
interest rates in 1825 Argentina
defaulted two years later it took
another 30 years for Argentina to resume
payments on their debt then in 1890
Argentina went on borrow and spree to
build transportation and infrastructure
the Commodities bubble bursts the nation
halted debt payments spring a run on
Argentine Banks and the resignation of
the president they borrowed more money
from the UK to prevent total insolvency
then it comes to 19 51 immigrants and
foreign Capital fueled Argentina's rise
to the top 10 richest countries by the
early 1913s World War one and Great
Depression destroyed the economy
unemployment and social unrest soared in
1938 coup brought the military into
Power creating a period of political
instability eight presidents in two
decades and a policy of import
substitution which closed off the
economy and helped trigger a default
then you have the next one here one
Peron Rose to power and 46 nationalizing
companies redistributing wealth and
asserting government control over the
economy the policies he and his wife
Avida carried out would become
Argentina's dominant governing principle
for roughly half of the next seven
decades in 1955 Peron was ousted in a
coup plunging the economy into turmoil
and leaving the country unstable to keep
up the debt payments the next year the
military Junta struck a deal with Paris
Club of creditor Nations to avert a
larger default if you're watching the
same pad which leader are we talking
about are we talking about the Vita with
Madonna playing the role of Evita where
she sang Don't Cry For Me the Argentina
the truth is I never left you that's the
same Evita Madonna play the Vita and
while I went to Buenos Aires and I went
to her plant of where she was buried
there were people standing there crying
on one end because she's a hero to many
we've got a lot of entitlement programs
and there was another group that said
her and her husband destroyed Argentina
then we have 1982 during Argentina's
dirty word the military dictatorship
borrowed mainly from U.S and British
Banks to fund infrastructure projects
and state industry the nation's forward
that skyrocketed from 8 billion to 46
billion dollars commodity prices
collapsed again when the Federal Reserve
under the leadership of chairman Paul
Walker raised U.S interest rates to as
high as 20 percent to tame inflation
this per debt crisis across Latin
America and the rest of the developing
World Argentina became one of 27 Nations
including 16 in Latin America to
reschedule its debt then we come to 1989
to contain the recession that followed
on from the crisis Argentina started
printing money inflation Rose to over
three thousand percent forcing another
default in 1989 brought peronis leader
Carlos menem into Power his government
reduced inflation privatized State
companies and attracted foreign direct
Investments steered the nation from
recession to double-digit growth by
Eminem's second before you're in office
Argentina's foreign debt search to more
than a hundred billion dollars because
of menense inability to reign in
spending by the time he left the nation
had fallen into recession once more amid
Rising unemployment constraint exports
and an overvalued pesos so look good
first when he's getting all this debt oh
my God this guy's caring about us and
then all of a sudden is like hey guys
we're in debt but listen my term my job
is done you guys take care of this stuff
let it be the next person's problem but
not mine then it comes 2001 a brutal
four-year recession wiped out roughly
two-thirds of Argentina's GDP Argentina
ride it around the rally and cry all of
them must go all of them must go the
country had five presidents in two weeks
all the while declaring what was at the
time the largest default by a country in
history payments were halted on 95
billion worth of bonds that led to
restructure and deal with creditors in
2005 and 2010 under Nestor Kirchner and
his wife Christina Fernandez most
bondholders agreed to take 30 cents on a
dollar offered but a contingent led by
hedge fund billionaire Paul singer held
out and demanded full repayment and then
comes today so pledging fiscal austerity
free market reforms and a return to
growth macri pulled in billions of
dollars of financing from foreign
creditors however his reform agenda
quickly stalled in Congress and the
economy never picked up leaving the
country stuck with a severe debt that it
struggled to repay officials turned once
again to the IMF to hop and secure a 56
billion auto credit line in 2018 it was
the biggest Aid package by the IMF
international monetary fund had ever
handed out and yet ultimately mattered
little investors were already convinced
by then that this episode 2 would end
badly and were pulling money out of the
country at a rapid Pace then came the
final blow Alberto Fernandez a leftist
leader who had played a key role in the
kirschner administration who won a
primary vote in a landslide that year
that all guaranteed but his victory over
macri in general election by the next
day Traders had pushed the price of the
country's bonds down to less than 50
cents on the dollar and acknowledgment
essentially that they knew a default and
restruction was inevitable so I want you
to think about how did you get here
here's a country there is data like
everything we're talking about they have
access to yet 16 out of 20 presidents
are peyronis like I'll give you an idea
think about this policy hey if you vote
me in you will no longer have to pay
your electrical bill it'll be five
dollars a month what an awesome Noble
policy I want this guy in yes and that's
exactly what they did five bucks a month
but the GDP of Argentina spends two to
three percent of their GDP to pay for
the electricity that the workers are
paying for but the people that are not
working they just pay five bucks a month
how does that make any sense it's easy
it's exciting but it comes on the backs
of all the people that are working
here's another one I'll tell you another
subsidy for you to be thinking about
when it comes down to agriculture guess
what country leads the world for the
biggest percentage when it comes down to
agriculture you guessed it right look at
this chart according to statista
Argentina is at minus 2.6 you know what
this means they're paying out of their
GDP towards the agriculture that people
get and it looks Again Noble but it's on
the backs of the workers so so what
happens when this takes place here's
what here's what Argentina has to do
they have to often resort to price
controls to combat inflation as of 2023
there were price caps on over 1300
consumer products and one-third of the
workforce currently is employed by the
state one-third of the workforce is
employed by the state who pays for their
salary taxpayers the same people that
voted 16 out of 20 peronis candidates
and why is this important because most
of their expenditure instead of
investing into possibilities of
innovation technology all this stuff
they're investing towards salaries and
pensions they're not investing into
infrastructure so obviously these types
of policies causes them to be a fiscally
deficit for the last 13 years constantly
Printing and borrowing money the biggest
IMF borrower a third of all of IMF debts
is Argentina when I look at this chart
here from March 31st 2023 three look at
the green America how big is Argentina
majority of the debt that IMF has lended
out is to Argentina then you have Egypt
then Ukraine they're nearly three four
times as big as Ukraine's death is what
Argentina currently has so so why is
this a problem for Argentina because IMF
wants the debt to be paid back in
dollars but Argentina doesn't want
dollars leaving so when you think about
this August 2023 Argentina's economy
Minister Sergio Masa said Argentina
would not use a single dollar of its own
reserves to make the IMF repayment so so
you borrowed money from IMF now you're
saying no I know you just won dollars
I'm not going to do it for you what do
you want to do about it in 2021
Argentina restricted exports of certain
cuts of beef and caps exports at 50 of
last year's average export Pace until
the end of 2021 these were an effort by
Argentina to limit export in order to
curb domestic food inflation and if you
look at Farmers they have a 33 percent
export tax on soybeans in 2023 this is a
way of them trying to prevent dollars
from leaving Argentina and by the way it
doesn't stop with soybeans and beef
concerts yes concerts they have this
thing called the dollar Coldplay concert
concert promoters booking artists who
charge in foreign currency will pay a 30
tax which is passed on to the fans on
top of the cost of the ticket it's
informally named after the British rock
band which played 10 sold out shows in
bonus Iris last year the dollar Coldplay
and by the way as if it's not already
bad enough statista has this report here
Source IMF saying what's going to happen
to the general government's expenditure
of Argentina from 2006 to 2028. look at
the number here where it's at at 2023
and then look where it goes in 24 25 26
27 28 if they go the way they're going
right now as bad as things are in
Argentina it's about to get 10 times
worse so this brings me back to the
candidate that's running the Elvis
Presley looking candidate Javier Mele
that's a libertarian maker who is fiery
feisty loud piss on a lot of people off
but at the same time gaining a ton of
support he is the leading presidential
candidate for Argentina's 2023
presidential election he is campaigning
on the idea of dollarizing the economy
to stabilize inflation blow up central
banks today most citizens of Argentina
save in dollars to preserve their wealth
but they are only allowed to buy two
hundred dollars per month at the
official exchange rate because of this
there's a huge black market for currency
exchange citizens are charged a much
higher price to buy dollars on the black
market so what does Dollar Rising the
economy mean and does it fix the problem
it means adapting the US dollar as the
legal tender in unit of account full
dollarization means all local currency
and circulation is exchanged for
greenbacks and all assets and contracts
are converted to dollars so who uses the
dollar besides the U.S Panama Ecuador El
Salvador and to more or less days so why
would a country do this by adopting
another currency a country gives up the
power to print more money and thus
eliminates the main driver of inflation
it acknowledges a loss of faith in the
ability of elected and appointed
officials to maintain a sustainable
fiscal policy the IMF said the main
attraction of full dollarization is the
elimination of the risk of a sudden
sharp devaluation of the country's
exchange rate and what's the downside
the biggest problem associated with the
dollarization is the loss of an
independent monetary policy so how does
this apply to you why should you and I
know about this because many many years
ago this happened America when FDR came
up with Social Security came up with the
welfare program and then Lyndon Johnson
made it even worse in 1964-65 and the
whole idea was we're going to eliminate
poverty after the Great Depression by
putting a bunch of money from taxpayers
into poor people and eventually this is
going to be gone because we're going to
solve this problem it took us 55 years
to realize it was a failure look at this
chart right here when we first started
the percentage of population of poverty
if you look at the chart there was at 15
percent do you see all the way to the
left the 1966 chart this is right after
Lyndon Johnson the total federal welfare
spending including Medicaid located in
19 166 was barely anything two percent
and then all of a sudden 1996 what
happens the expenditure crosses the
percentage of population percentage of
population of poverty stays the same but
the debt and the amount of money we
spend skyrockets and now good luck
finding a candidate to go out there and
say guys we got to cut this entitlement
program we got to cut this welfare
anybody who runs on that ain't nobody
going to be voting for those guys who've
been taking advantage of these
entitlement programs this is why it's
important to know if America goes the
way it's going Argentina is around the
corner and by the way you know
Argentina's most important natural
resource that they had you know what
happened to the most important natural
resource he now lives in my community
his name is Messi Lionel Messi left and
he now lives in Fort Lauderdale place
for inner Miami if it's so great why
wouldn't Messi go back because bad
policies push the guy out goes to Europe
and he doesn't want to go back home he
comes to the U.S that's what bad
policies do so if you've got value out
of this video give it a thumbs up
subscribe to the channel and if you want
to watch another video like this on
where America is at would welfare
entitlement programs click here to watch
the video take care everybody bye-bye
bye-bye
foreign
[Music]